>> WE ARE BUILDING A LOT OF WALL
AND WE ARE BUILDING A LOT MORE.
WHEN IT IS ALL COMPLETED OUT, IT
WILL BE 115 MILES.
THAT IS A LOT.
WE’RE TALKING ABOUT 500 MILES.
I AM GOING THERE.
I ASSUME YOU ARE COMING WITH ME
ON THE END OF JANUARY.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE NANCY PELOSI
IS CALLING THE SHOTS, NOT CHUCK.
CHUCK WANTS TO HAVE THE SHOTS, I
BELIEVE THAT.
SHE IS CALLING THE SHOTS.
SHE IS CALLING THEM BECAUSE SHE
WANTS THE VOTES.
>> Bret: STILL TRY TO GET THE
DETAILS OF THAT CONTRACT ON THE
BORDER WALL, BORDER SECURITY
WHILE TRAVELING TO SEE TROOPS
OVERSEAS.
HE TWEETED, "HOW THE DEMOCRATS
REALIZE THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED
BORDER SECURITY AND TO WALL?
NEED TO STOP DRUGS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, AND CRIMINALS
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
TWO THEY REALIZE THAT MOST OF
THE PEOPLE NOT GETTING PAID ARE
DEMOCRATS?
HE ALSO TWEETED THERE IS A
FULL-SCALE MANHUNT GOING OUT IN
CALIFORNIA FOR AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT ACCUSED OF SHOOTING
AND KILLING A POLICE OFFICER
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
TIME TO GET TOUGH ON BORDER
SECURITY AND BUILD A WALL.
THERE IS A MANHUNT UNDERWAY.
THE SHERIFF DOES PRETTY TAME THE
SUSPECT WAS SEEN
ON CAMERA BUYING BEER AT A
CONVENIENCE STORE.
THEY BELIEVE HE IS AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT.
HE SHOT AND KILLED AN OFFICER
WEDNESDAY AFTER BEING PULLED
OVER IN A GRAY PICKUP TRUCK.
THAT IS ALL THE BACKDROP TO
WHICH THIS PARTIAL GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN CONTINUES.
LET’S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
JASON WIDELY, SENIOR FELLOW AT
THE MANHATTAN INSTITUTE.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, EDITOR AT THE
FEDERALISTS.
AMY WALTER, THE NATIONAL EDITOR
FOR THE POLITICAL REPORT.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
CONTEXT HERE IN THE     THE BIGP
CONTEXT HERE IN THE     THE BIGC
CONTEXT HERE IN THE     THE BIGU
CONTEXT HERE IN THE     THE BIGE
ON ALL OF THIS?
>> THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE
PUSHING FOR TRUMP TO ABANDON ANY
WALL FUNDING.
THAT IS VERY UNREALISTIC.
THE SMARTER MOVE WOULD BE FOR
DEMOCRATS TO OFFER SOME FUNDING
IN RETURN FOR SOMETHING THEY
WANT SUCH AS AMNESTY FOR THE
DREAMERS WERE VERY POPULAR FOR
BOTH PARTIES.
IN THE SHORT RUN I DON’T THINK
THAT THIS SHUTDOWN IS HEARD IN
THE PRESIDENTS.
THESE SUPPORTERS WANT TO COME HE
CAMPAIGNED ON IT.
THEY WANT HIM TO FULFILL A
CAMPAIGN POP TO MAKE PROMISE AND
HE HAS BECOME CONVINCED THAT IF
HE DOESN’T PUSH FOR THIS WALL
AND SHOW SOME PROGRESS ON THIS
FRONT HE WILL HURT HIS STANDING
WITH HIS BASE.
HE COULD BE RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
THE ARGUMENT FOR HIM DOING
SOMETHING NOW VERSUS NEXT YEAR,
I THINK HE HAS A STRONGER HAND
RIGHT NOW.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER, AT
$5 BILLION THAT WAS APPROVED
EARLIER THIS MONTH GOES IN
JANUARY.
WHEN NANCY PELOSI WRITES A NEW
BELT WITH HER POCKET, IT WILL
CONTAIN LESS THAN $5 BILLION.
>> Bret: AMY, THIS
HUNT
FOR THIS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
WHO SHOT
AND KILLED A POLICE OFFICER, THE
SHERIFF’S OFFICE OUT THERE IS
TALKING ABOUT THE OFFICER WHO
WAS KILLED.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> HE WAS A POLICE OFFICER, WHAT
NEEDS TO BE KNOWN IS THAT HE WAS
TRULY JUST A HUMAN BEING.
AN AMERICAN PATRIOT.
HE WAS NOT BORN IN AMERICA, HE
WAS BORN IN FIJI.
HE CAME TO THIS COUNTRY WITH ONE
PURPOSE AND THAT WAS TO SERVE
THIS COUNTRY.
>> Bret: THE 33-YEAR-OLD WAS
KILLED AND THAT SHOOTING.
WE HAVE SEEN THE SENTENCE IT WAS
BEFORE
THE CASE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
AFFECTED THE BROADER PICTURE AND
BORDER SECURITY.
AS IS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS?
>> IT IS A HORRIBLE AND TRAGIC
STORY.
YOU ARE RIGHT TO NOTE THAT WE
HAVE HAD A LOT OF STORIES LIKE
THIS.
WE’VE HAD A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE WALL.
WE’VE HAD THE CARAVAN, WE’VE HAD
AN ELECTION, WE HAVE HAD
PLURALIZATION OF THE WELL
THROUGHOUT THE LAST TWO YEARS.
WE LOOK AT OPINIONS OF THE WALL,
THEY HAVE NOT CHANGED SINCE
THE 2016 CAMPAIGN.
I WENT BACK AND I LEFT.
THE POLL, 42% OPPOSITION, TWO
YEARS LATER AND WE ARE IN
DECEMBER OF 2018.
43% AND 54% DISAGREE.
WITH THE IDEA OF A WALL.
THESE LAST TWO YEARS, WE’VE NOT
THE REALITY IS THAT WE HAVE OVER
SEEN ANY MINDS CHANGED ON THE
OPINION OF THE WALT DESPITE ALL
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON AROUND IT.
INSTEAD WHAT WE ARE
GETTING, BROADENING OF
COALITIONS FOR EITHER SIDE.
THEY ARE HARDENING AND
DEEPENING.
>> Bret: >> Bret: MOLLY?
>> YOU ARE SEEING THAT IN THE
SHUTDOWN OF THE GOVERNMENT.
BOTH SIDES THINK THEY HAVE THE
UPPER HAND.
DEMOCRATS REALLY BELIEVE THAT
DENYING TRUMP A VICTORY ON
BORDER WALL FUNDING IS
ABSOLUTELY KEY.
THEY KNOW THIS WAS SOMETHING HE
CAMPAIGNED ON AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT DOES HAVE A LOT
OF SUPPORT.
THAT HAS A HUGE BACKING.
EVEN MORE THAN A WALL, THEY ARE
GREATER CONCERNS ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY WHICH I THINK IS A MUCH
MORE COMPROMISED POSITION THAT
PEOPLE ON BOTH LEFT AND RIGHT
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT.
AT THE SAME TIME, TRUMP THINKS
HE HAS A STRONG HAND BECAUSE 75%
OF THE GOVERNMENT IS FUNDED.
HE THINKS HE CARES ABOUT THIS
ISSUE AND HE IS WILLING TO GET
CREDIT FOR SHOWING ON THE
GOVERNMENT COME HE CARE SO MUCH
THAT HE WILL GO TO THAT EXTENT.
THERE IS THIS INTRACTABILITY IN
THIS FIGHT.
I THINK WHILE THE WALL ITSELF
MIGHT BE WITH NUMBERS THAT AMY
IS TALKING ABOUT THE CONCERN
ABOUT BORDER SECURITY IS A
LONG-STANDING CONCERN THAT GOES
BACK DECADES.
THERE IS A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
AND THAT THE GOVERNMENT HAS DONE
SO LITTLE TO ENSURE THE SECURITY
OF OUR BORDERS.
>> Bret: WE SET PETER DOOCY UP
ON CAPITOL HILL BASICALLY, THE
ONLY PERSON UP ON CAPITOL HILL.
IT SEEM LIKE THERE WERE
TUMBLEWEEDS GOING DOWN THE HALL.
HE’LL BE THERE UNTIL MONDAY, THE
BLAME GAME CONTINUES.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS, TAKE
A LISTEN.
>> THE NEEDLE HAS MOVED TOWARDS
A VERY LONG SHOT DOWN.
THE IMPASSE THAT WE ARE SEEING
ON THE UNWILLINGNESS OF
DEMOCRATS TO ACTUALLY ENGAGE IN
MEANINGFUL DIALOGUE.
MEAL
>> PUBLIC SERVANTS WANT TO GO TO
WORK.
THEY DON’T WANT TO BE IDLE.
THEY DON’T WANT TO THINK THIS
COULD GO ON FOR WEEKS.
IT IS A GREAT THING TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION UNDER THE
OUTGOING REPUBLICAN CONGRESS,
WE’VE HAVE ARRIVED AT THIS KIND
OF POINTS.
>> Bret: JUST THE PAST MINUTE,
THE PRESIDENT WEEDING OUT, THIS
ISN’T ABOUT THE WALL.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT A WALL WILL
WORK PERFECTLY.
IN ISRAEL THE WALL WORKS 99.9%.
THIS IS ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS NOT
LETTING THE REPUBLICANS HAVE A
WIN.
THEY HAVE THE TEN SENATE VOTES,
BUT WE HAVE THE BORDER SECURITY
2020.
THAT WAS TWEETED A FEW MINUTES
AGO.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S
RIGHT.
THIS IS ABOUT THE RESISTANCE NOT
WANTING TO GIVE HIM ANY COURT OR
ON ANY ISSUE.
INCLUDING THIS ISSUE.
IN THE LARGER SENSE, THE PUBLIC
IS WITH THE PRESIDENT -- BUILT
IN THE SENSE OF BORDER SECURITY
MUCH MORE THAN DEMOCRATS SEEM TO
CARE ABOUT BORDER SECURITY.
WE SEE THIS NOT ONLY IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO PHYSICAL BARRIERS,
WE SEE THIS IN THEIR TAX ON
I.C.E., BORDER ENFORCEMENT.
THEY JUST ARE NOT --
THEY DON’T LOOK SERIOUS ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY.
>> Bret: WHY DIDN’T THAT WORK
FOR THE MIDTERMS?
WHY DIDN’T IT WORK IN THE
DISTRICTS THAT WERE SUBURBS
OUTSIDE OF BIG CITIES?
WHY DIDN’T THE ISSUE WORK?
OBVIOUSLY THE PRESIDENT WAS
HEADING IT HARD THEY LEAD UP.
>> THERE WERE OTHER CONCERNS
THAT PEOPLE HAD IN THEIR MIND.
THE PUBLIC TO CREATE THE PUBLIC
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE, TOOK
CONTROL OVER THE DEMOCRATS.
I DON’T KNOW, IF TRUMP DIDN’T
HARP ON THIS THE LOSSES WOULD
EVENT EVEN GREATER THAN THEY
WERE.
THINK THAT IS HIS THINKING ON
THAT IS DIFFICULT TO PROVE BUT I
THIS ISSUE.
HIS BASE IS WITH HIM ON THIS.
IN THE SHORT RUN, I DON’T SEE
HIM FEELING A LOT OF PAIN ON
THIS ONE.
IF THIS GOES ON AND ON, THEN
PERHAPS YOU WILL SEE SOME
NEGATIVE RESPONSE TO TRUMP ON
THIS ISSUE.
NOT RIGHT NOW.
IT HAS BEEN GOING ON NOT LONG
ENOUGH.
FOR YOURSELF OR AWAY FROM 2020.
I DON’T THINK IT WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THAT EITHER.
DO WE GET A DEAL?
>> WE WILL NOT GET A DEAL UNTIL
THE NEW CONGRESS IS IN PLACE AND
EVEN THEN WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A
DEBATE FOR A LITTLE.
AT SOME POINT THERE ARE NO
WINNERS IN THIS SPIRIT THEY ARE
ONLY LOSERS.
IT HAS A QUESTION OF WHO LOOKS
LESS BAD.
>> I THINK THERE IS ROOM FOR A
WIN HERE, DEMOCRATS CAN BRING
BACK TALK TALK ABOUT RESOLVING
THAT ISSUE WITHOUT HAVING TO DO
CORPORATION SETTLE EVERYTHING.
YOU CAN GET BORDER SECURITY, A